آخر معركة قادها صدام حسين
معركة ستظل خالدة في التاريخ
، وستدرس في الكليات العسكرية
، جيش صدام محاصر ل١١ عاما
، واستطاع إلحاق الهزيمة بجيش أمريكا في وقت قياسي،
معركة أقرب لكونها محرقة،
المعركة التي دخل الأمريكان فيها
وهم متأكدون من النصر وبوقت قليل
لكن ما حدث هو عكس ذلك
(معركة مطار بغداد. للقصة بقية)
عندما قدم الاحتلال الأمريكي ليحتل بغداد عام ٢٠٠٣،
تسارعت الأحداث عندها،
وتقدمت قوات المحتل بشكل سريع نحو العاصمة بغداد،
حينها وصل خبر لقيادة الأركان الأمريكية
يفيد بأن الرئيس العراقي و٥٠٠ من ضباطه،
مجتمعون لمناقشة المعركة في قاعة داخل مطار بغداد الدولي
، ولأن قيادة قوات الاحتلال غبية على ما يبدو
، فقد صدقوا الخبر، بينما كان وزير الدفاع العراقي
سلطان هاشم أحمد هو من يتواجد في المطار
بأمر من القائد صدام حسين،
ويجهز مع قواته لمشهد سيكتب في التاريخ
وسيكون حبره هو الدم الأمريكي،
ولن ترى القوات الأمريكية مثله،
وعملت القوات بخطة سلطان هاشم،
وتم توزيعها على مدارج المطار التي تبلغ،
١٤ مدرجا، فتم تعطيل ٧ مدارج
والإبقاء على ال٧ البقية،
ليضمن عدم تشتيت قواته وحصر الهبوط إلى موقع واحد،
صدام وسلطان هاشم
رميا الخبر للاستخبارات الأمريكية كطعم،
عن طريقة أحد عملاء الCIA
الذي كان يعمل معهم في الظاهر وأخفى كونه عنصرا
في استخبارات صدام،
ولما وصل الخبر للقيادة الأمريكية،
جهزت وحدات من نخبة مقاتليها
من الفرقة ١٠١، حينها تم رفع حواف على كل مدرج
من المدارج ال٧، وتم ملؤها بالماء
لإخفاء أسلاك الكهرباء من الضغط العالي
التي تم إخفاؤها، وتم تجهيز مكان هبوط الطائرات
بشبكة هندسية من ألغام الفسفور،
وحان الموعد بوصول ٩ طائرات محملة بالجنود الأمريكان،
وهبطت الطائرات إلا الطائرة التاسعة
فقد كانت مجهزة لحمل الأسرى
وحين علموا أنهم وقعوا في الفخ
استطاعت هذه الطائرة، الإقلاع مجدد
قبل أن تهبط كليا واستطاعت النجاة بطاقمها،
لكن الطائرات ال٨ المتبقية كانت قد هبطت في المكان المحدد،
وهناك بدأت الألغام بالانفجار وسُمع دي هذه الانفجارات المروعة
في أرجاء العاصمة بغداد،
فاصطادهم صدام في الوقت الذي أتوا لاصطياده،
وكان من يستطيع النجاة من الألغام
لا بد وأن يضع قدمه في الماء المبطن بأسلاك الضغط العالي
وبالتالي، من لم يمت باللغم مات مصعوقاً،
وتم إبادة ٢٠١٩ جنديا من النخبة الأمريكية
في الفرقة ١٠١
أما في غرفة عمليات قيادة الاحتلال
فكان رئيسهم جورج بوش وقادة جيشه،
يتابعون هذه العملية أولا بأول،
وعندما علموا بالمحرقة التي حصلت بقواتهم،
أراد جورج بوش إيقاف عملية الاحتلال بالكامل،
إلا أن ديك شيني خالفه الرأي
وحثه على الاستمرار في المعارك في كل الجبهات
وتعد هذه المعركة التي لم تدم سوى ثوانٍ قليلة
أحد الأسباب لإعدام صدام حسين،
فيما كان قد صدر حكم بالإعدام على سلطان هاشم،
لكنه لم ينفذ وظل سجينا،،،
لم يحتج صدام ووزيره سلطان هاشم
إلا بعض التجهيزات ومعلومة خاطئة تصل للعدو
، في المقابل فقد حققا نصرا تاريخيا في بضع ثوان؟
فأين القادة اليوم مما كان عليه صدام حينها؟...